california's iconic sequoias are the
largest trees on earth
these giants have lived for thousands of
years
surviving war
famine and the rise of globalization
but california's ongoing drought
could mean disaster
these enormous trees are already showing
signs of weakness never seen before
anthony ambrose and a team of
researchers are heading into the forest
to climb hundreds of feet in the air
and see what can be done to save these
magnificent trees
[Music]
our research entails climbing the giant
sequoia trees
and
measuring their water status basically
an index of how stressed they are
relative to
the environment
the water status of all plants is kind
of like the equivalent of blood pressure
in that human it's just a basic measure
of how much water they have available to
them to continue
to function and grow so we clip little
shoots of foliage and
we put the little piece of foliage leaf
end down into this pressurized chamber
and the amount of pressure it takes to
push the water back out of the stem
is equal to the amount of tension it was
under when you cut that piece of foliage
when water availability declines such as
during a drought that creates a lot more
tension in the tree
when the tension becomes too great
then tiny little air bubbles form in the
wood and when it gets bad enough then
the plant suffers and starts to die
[Music]
there's a couple reasons why we need to
climb to the tops of these trees
[Music]
as water moves up the tree it's fighting
gravity and friction and the top of the
tree is going to be the most stressed
part of the tree so in order to get a
really good idea of how stressed they
are we need to go to the very tippy top
[Music]
it's a really humbling experience
because you're up in the crown of these
massive ancient things and they make you
feel small
i'm at the top of a very large giant
sequoia tree we're waiting for the
sunrise because it's really really
pretty this morning
it's important to realize and remember
that these trees have been living for
thousands of years and they've dealt
with pretty severe events fires and
droughts in the past and they're
amazingly resilient one of the things
that really is remarkable about these
trees is their ability to recover from
drought type events
the question is as conditions change as
temperatures continue to increase
globally are conditions going to change
to a point where they may reach some
threshold where they're not able to
recover from these type of events
[Music]
it's an absolutely amazing unique
experience to be able to climb into
these trees we want to preserve them we
want them to be here and we want them to
be healthy and happy
[Music]